the leaders of Libya's warring sighs are
in the Russian capital for talks after a
ceasefire came into force
now it's raised hopes that the warlord
Khalifa Haftar and the Prime Minister of
the UN recognized government faces Suraj
will begin to find a path towards ending
years of civil conflict international
diplomatic efforts to end the fighting
have stepped up in recent weeks a truce
brokered by Turkey and Russia came into
force on Sunday morning and both
Turkey's president and Italy's Prime
Minister have announced that they will
attend a Libya peace conference in
Berlin later this month we support plans
for the Berlin conference and myself the
Russian President Vladimir Putin and the
Italian Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte
will all be in attendance mr. Putin and
I agreed to reach a ceasefire in Libya
the ceasefire which began on Sunday and
our delegations are now in Moscow to
discuss this and I hope it will be
permanent we have three correspondents
covering this story mahmoud abdullah had
will join us from tripoli we have a son
who's a Moscow where the talks are
happening right now but first we'll
bring in jamal al he's journey joining
us in the turkish a capital ankara and
as these meetings are underway right now
in moscow Jamaa the Turkish and Italian
leaders were in Ankara what was the
message that they sent out well they're
in they had a meeting earlier on Monday
where they discussed the way forward
with regards to the situation in Libya
and it seems that at least based on the
joint statements that was made between
the president Rajab Shaban and Italy's
Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte that
things are moving in a positive way in
fact the Italian Prime Minister spent
quite a lot of his time talking about
how not just important the situation in
Libya was and how there was a dire need
to bring about some sort of stability
but also reiterating his belief that
things were moving forward positively
the situation in Libya is very important
and we've agreed there must be a
ceasefire the turkey Russia agreement
will help a lot in this regard and now
we have a window of opportunity that's
been opened and we want this window to
pay for the way for a lasting peace in
the region
as far as Italy is concerned obviously
it has specific concerns with regards to
the instability and war there because
any war results in the displacement of
people on a lot of migration has taken
place from Libya towards Italy as a
consequence obviously it has other
interests considering it is a former
colonizer of Libya and still maintains a
lot of interests economic particular
with regards to the North African
country turkey also has a lot of its
national security as well as foreign
policy agenda based on Libya already has
military presence in the wider Middle
East and North Africa region but has
signed bilateral agreements with the
government in Tripoli which has allowed
for it to send troops to Libya that's
probably arguably one of the major
shifts in the power plays that have
taken place that has allowed for or
maybe forced some sorts of a discussion
process to begin not least also to
mention Turkey's interests with regards
to mining and extracting natural
resources in the Mediterranean Sea
considering the two countries share
maritime borders so Turkey will be
pursuing this very vigorously as it has
over the past few weeks and all the
signs show that as things gear up from
the meetings that took place between
Iran and prime minister Suraj in
Istanbul 24 hours ago now these meetings
that took place between him and the
Italian prime minister and then moving
forward to this Berlin conference that
there is at least some semblance of a
process that could provide some sort of
hope that is the fighting will end or at
least pause for a while okay in Jemile
thank you for that update from Ankara
let's bring in Steve Fossen she's
joining us from Moscow to discuss more
of that process that Jamal was just
referring to him particularly what's
happening right now in Moscow and if we
have any information on whether half
that and Saroj themselves will be
meeting
well our own Moscow right now where the
meeting has been going on for more than
six hours already and I have to say
tension is building up a bit because
there hasn't been a word coming from
these closed meetings since the
beginning only from president Erdogan
who was far away in Ankara who said that
there are some positive messages coming
from this meeting we're actually waiting
for a while already for a statement by
the Minister of Foreign Affairs from
Russia anthem Foreign Affairs from
Turkey who have been actually initiating
this this meeting and who started the
meeting both our Libyan warring sites
are in the ministries building as well
we don't know for sure if they have met
a face to face or if they have met the
delegations of the ministers separately
this is all what we want to hear of
course in this press statement we also
want to hear how this fragile situation
in Libya how this is going to be
transformed in this ceasefire and what
they hope to achieve is that the
signatures will actually be put under
this ceasefire somehow later today and
this will pave the way for this
international conference in Libya which
was Germany hoping to organize within a
week from now but it's a very of course
crucial meeting and we can see that
Turkey and Russia here have a very
important role in the in brokering
decided ceasefire okay step we'll cross
back to you a little later for the time
being thank you let's bring in Mohammed
Abdullah who joins us from Tripoli so
all these meetings taking place outside
of Libya discussing Libya Mahmoud and
what happens really what's important is
what happens on the ground where you are
we understand there's a ceasefire that's
meant to be in place just bring us up to
speed with what you're hearing
well Doreen the situation has changed it
on the front lines this is the
escalation has been very notable during
the past 24 hours with the exception of
deployment deployment and also
regrouping repositioning by Hefner's
forces in several axis in southern
Tripoli that's according to a government
military sources and meanwhile people
here in Tripoli the AU are hopeful that
these peace peace talks will come up
with a solution to this conflict here
also the Madiga airport the only
operational airport in tripoli that was
closed down because of multiple attacks
by half those forces over the past
months has now resumed aviation taking
the opportunity of the de-escalation
atmosphere but in fact the government of
national court has repeatedly called for
half the resources to pull out from
southern tripoli as a prerequisite for
any peaceful talks but meanwhile a
terrain here in the west of Libya this
is the camp led by the government of
national Accord many institutions
including political parties and along
with the religious Endowment institution
here they have one also one demand is to
have the resources should pull out from
southern troops southern tripoli as a
condition for these peace negotiations
to go on but meanwhile it seems that the
gap between the two camps is very wide
and it's really needs a lot of time and
effort to be bridged we're getting
reports from the city after Hoonah the
major supporter of the warlord relief
after and in fact it has a central
command for Hathor's forces there that
the elderly council is now blaming
Hoefler for what they call not
consulting them in this meeting he has
not spoken with them before he decided
to go to Moscow and meet with the
mediators but meanwhile we're getting
also reports from Moscow there in that
the two delegations have
not met face-to-face and Hefner's
delegation is until now is rejecting the
Turks to be the mediator in this
ceasefire call in all cases doreen the
situation remains very tense and south
of tripoli despite despite the fact that
it has been quiet over the past 24 hours
about all eyes like step sad are now on
Moscow to see what conclusions will come
out of this meeting yeah and we wait to
see what comes out of Moscow Mahmoud
I'll let you go for now for the time
being thank you for that update from
Tripoli itself let's speak to Mustafa
fitori he's a Libyan academic he's also
a contributor to a monitor he's joining
us a via Skype from Paris good to have
you with us on the al Jazeera news hour
what are the chances of success coming
out of Moscow thank you for having me
there een I think the chances are 50/50
no more than that I think the most
sticking boring to probably is what your
reporter from Tripoli asking just
suggested and that is the condition of
having half the force of the blow from
southern Germany and of course I do not
see how much traffic could accept that
condition because simply it could mean
defeat I'm lost
the other point he mentioned your
reporter mentioned about the Civic their
own about 80 kilometers south of tripoli
and it's the main supply point and
control point for after and forces and
of course if he leaves that area there
would be there would be any french
against aruna and so I don't really see
now how you could accept any condition
that means to bring April 3rd mind we
are not fear so if you're saving so if
you're saying that tough that is not
willing to accept that precondition of
backing away from Tripoli to pre April
days then what is he willing to to back
away from and if he's not going to
accept any conditions then why would he
participate in these meetings
well let's to we're here to see it to
say me because we won't we already have
ceasefire okay that's fine but the point
is these fighters always have to have
thermals and conditions that go along
with them and I would I would imagine
that means to happen with the Bologna
would've only accept something like a
limited withdrawal of horses from
southern children we'd say like 20
kilometres away 40 kilometres away but I
don't even see him taking his bosses all
the way back to the positions they were
controlling to achieve so what is he
hoping to achieve well the entire thing
of the the chief I hold the gun die
think above me what mr. Astor is trying
to achieve and in this case to have say
during the upcoming Berlin conference
whenever it takes place because we have
seen before that the Germans are not
very interested or very inclined if you
like to invite him neither salon and now
there is a different talk above me that
would be one of the in the agreement and
we'll need to have some time at least to
say that I have tried to have ceasefire
in reasonable ways for me but the other
side in this case governor say accord
did not accept it okay we'll leave it
there we thank you very much most of a
fitori for speaking to us from France
thank you
let's not bring in no matter when
Bashara he's al jazeera senior political
analyst joining us right here in doha so
what is the significance of the
convergence of all these sort of
regional and international players
coming together to discuss libya well
this was the plan the plan advanced by
the United Nations several months ago
was that there needs to be a three-phase
process and that's why apparently your
guests did not get the three-phase
process involves first a ceasefire
ceasefire meaning stop shooting that's
just up shooting
second there will be a meeting in Berlin
and the meeting in Berlin is for the
stakeholders the non Libyans who have
been influencing the situation in Libya
one way or another so that they agree on
the general guidelines about what is
required from the Libyans themselves on
a road map of sort to arrive at a deal
which takes us to the third phase when
the parties within Libya namely Saroj
and after and their allies need to get
together and speak about political
solution because in the end of the day
the ceasefire is temporary
what Libya needs is a permanent solution
and that requires the international and
regional stakeholders agreeing and then
bringing in the Libyan parties in order
to talk about long-term solution does it
sound to you from what you've seen today
like they are agreeing because there are
several who have different stakes the
Libya it's actually worse than that I
mean you know allow me to vent because
we've been talking about this for eight
months for eight months the world was
recognizing a legitimate government in
Tripoli except on the ground and some of
the world states were supporting a
warlord called Khalifa Haftar
a warlord he was not recognized by
anyone until some regional parties
likely and I remember it's Egypt another
stepped in such supporting him and when
that happened he started making advances
and that's when all the parties that
were sitting on their hands sitting on
their hands like the Italians like the
French and others starting appeasing
after and we just saw the images and
we're seeing them now the images of
kunti the Iranian Prime Minister the
Italian Prime Minister with the Libyan
warlord total appeasement of someone
who's supposed to be recognized as a
warlord
that's what we got today we got today
because the Turks and they needs to be
giving credit the Turks decided that
this was time to step in and support the
UN recognized government in order to
balance the situation in Libya in order
to lead to a ceasefire and then do
something
I think that Turkish decision to get
involved is the one that got everyone
off their hands and start talking
seriously about ceasefire and a solution
in Libya and hence the Russian and the
Turks sort of embracing if you will
hosting this effort at this point in
time that will take us to Berlin where
are the others will also participate
looks to me like there are the best of
bad options in order to move the process
forward so does that sound to me then
like you're optimistic that something is
going to come out of Moscow if the Turks
are using their leverage and the
Russians use their leverage I think
sooner or later it's going to be clear
that once the the sort of this kind of
international pressure and an leverage
comes bring comes to bear that in then
they have they will have little option
but to play along because what would an
agreement look like now for now it's a
ceasefire ceasefire meaning let's all
stop shooting and let's then take
certain confidence-building measures to
return to certain lines at a certain
schedule within a certain time line that
allows more confidence-building measures
and Berlin is going to happen before the
end of the month that Berlin conference
and it's the stakeholders those who
support after and those who support
Suraj will be hopefully making more
positive instead of the last eight
months of negative contribution to the
Libyan situation again what we've
learned in this region I think the
Libyans are learning this slowly but
surely no one wins a civil war civil war
leaves everyone destroyed leaves the
country destroyed an eye for an eye
leaves everyone blind and sooner or
later they need to come together and
what will the end game looks like even
several months from now or years because
this will take time not the ceasefire
the protocol solution right Libya is
going to need a national army because
the problem now in the east and west of
Libya is that we have militias half that
leads a number of militias and Saroj
needs a number of militias the country
is divided among militias and warlords
what Libya needs today after the West
intervened in order to protect the
Libyan people was the destruction of the
Libyan National Army
so what Libya needs in the next several
months maybe years is to build a
national army
Aarav or without the militias in order
them to have that stability that the
country needs to move forward ok my
lambo shadow thank you very much